Rolf wir nun hin und in den deutschen
die sündhafte Lust an der Lichterkette
außer für den notlichen Auftrag jetzt
Herr gut dann machen wir es halt
die merken gar nicht dass die Leute
jetzt irgendwie sagen oh dieses Jahr
kaufen wir keine Lichterkette das merken
wir überhaupt nicht also
die Leute ballern so richtig die Kohle
raus
Lichterketten und für andere Dinge
20 30
Lichterketten
hoch ne sie haben Weihnachtsbaum der ist
8 Meter hoch und wir haben 20 30
geworden
fast immer was was war irgendwo noch
hinstellen können was wir immer noch
nicht haben das ist natürlich der
komplett falsche Einsatz in diesem Jahr
2022 wir haben Krise Herrn Frau Hoffmann
also wegen ihm muss der Olaf Scholz
jetzt extra Atomkraftwerk länger laufen
lassen damit sie ihren ihren Scheiß 8
Meter hohen Weihnachtsbaum da beleuchten
können
sie sich nicht eigentlich in Zeiten der
Krise
gelaufen damit sie ihre Lichterkette
draußen natürlich
dann zu machen ich weiß die Kerzen darf
man auch nicht mehr anmachen CO2 Problem
ja genau LEDs sind auch ja
wahrscheinlich wird wegen ihnen dass das
AKW Emsland laufen müssen
deswegen kaufen
die mit Strom betrieben werden damit das
AKW läuft jetzt ist jetzt hier mal
Schluss mit den ganzen Sachen ja jetzt
wird er immer ausmachen
das muss alles aus das muss alles aus
hier jetzt ist mal Schluss hier
machen ich versorge Norddeutschland mit
Erdgas
sie sind dafür verantwortlich dass es in
Deutschland Gas gibt dann können wir da
nicht irgendwie was machen also wie
gesagt ich habe auch besuchen oder sowas
meine Frau ist sehr temperaturfühlig
also wenn sie da vielleicht etwas
abzweigen könnten das immer so zwei
Plastiktüten voll mitbringen
ja wollen wir gleich mal Telefonnummer
ja ja was gibt's am 24 Abend und
Raclette Raclette Strom ja man kann sich
auch so man Käsebrot machen aber
brauchen wir nicht irgendwie extra diese
Wahnsinn dass der Käse unbedingt flüssig
sein muss
schießen da brauche ich keinen Strom für
ne so dann kriege ich Ärger mit dem
Behörden ja gut aber das wäre auch meine
wirklich konkreter Vorschlag warum muss
es Raclette sein Sie können sich doch
einfach Mann Hirschen schießen da muss
ich mal
Jesus direkt fragen dieses Jahr
Weihnachten so wie man es kennt ja aus
ne
für mich ja ich muss so Schicht
ach dieser ganze Weihnachts Kitsch kann
mir gestohlen bleiben obwohl eine
Verwendung hätte ich dafür
na also geht doch
frohe Weihnachten
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines Abo
bitten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
ja los du scheiß Pferd hey